how's it going red my name is forever
welcome to bromancing saga - I don't
know what the hell happened with
romancing saga number one but it's
probably one of the best titles ever
made bromance the saga to professional
man statins that is this way - awesome
it's actually a co-op game I was gonna
play with my girlfriend but she's not
here and I have no friends so pretty
much you press a and G and the other P
person has D and G so basically this is
how your play it's a making fun of co-op
games and huh well you'll see it's
bringing hell yeah
alright it's brofist in time [ __ ] hmm
yeah oh I'm actually doing pretty
[ __ ] well [ __ ] yeah what are you do
it one miss well [ __ ] it
85% sink rate mm do it through I can do
it one rule yes I'm gonna rock up nice
bun what yeah oh yeah what don't watch
my my name is looking oh thank you yes
it's so [ __ ] stupid
alright keep shouting them hell yeah
yeah bro good work ago what shun
alright I got a 40 percent sync great
1,700 nice one
oh we got a couple of many time
hey hey don't rob me yes just don't rap
come on truck come on it so I good
rubbing
oh they're both so awkward now yeah why
I got 91% synchrony mothership is
excluded oh no lately why - I just want
to tell you oh no this is so beautiful
is it such a nice moment
oh why did I see that it rotted that is
better love story than Twilight right
all right
this game is free so if you bros want to
check it out i'll leave a download link
in description
played with someone not so awkward
because it will don't worry it's not
worth it but if you have someone that
you will not be awkward with and go for
it anyway I got six thousand scores to
see if you can beat it with your bro
leave a video response and that's pretty
much it back a favorite it was a bonus
video my fans
I know it's short
anyway shoes we will take this why the
hell did I do it again okay take the
bomb and give it to the plank Pro crow
dammit
okay Leon Leon let's click this yeah cuz
everyone knows if you drop one tonne of
all right um Wow